This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. If I asked you what it means to be a good person, I'm guessing you would quickly rattle off a list of virtues. Good people are truthful. They're kind to others, helpful to those in need. They are loyal friends, generous, brave. They put the needs of others before their own needs. But if I were to ask you where those beliefs come from or why you think kindness and bravery and generosity are virtues, you might have to pause for a
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。如果我问你做一个好人意味着什么，我猜你会飞快地列出一系列美德。好人是诚实的。他们对他人友好，对需要帮助的人伸出援手。他们是忠诚的朋友、慷慨、勇敢。他们把别人的需求放在自己的需求之前。但如果我问你这些信念从何而来，或者为什么你认为善良、勇敢和慷慨是美德，你可能得停顿一
moment to think. Let's say I make it even more complicated. I give you a scenario about two brothers who love each other dearly. One does something wrong and the other has to decide whether to turn him in. The second brother must choose between honesty and loyalty. Which virtue is more important? If you picked one, do you know why you chose it? TV shows and movies are filled with these kinds of moral dilemmas because they provide dramatic tension.
下思考片刻。假设我把情况变得更复杂。我给你讲一个关于两个深爱彼此的兄弟的场景。其中一个人做了错事，另一个人必须决定是否要去告发他。第二个兄弟必须在诚实和忠诚之间做出选择。哪种美德更重要？如果你选了一个，你知道自己为什么选它吗？电视节目和电影里充满了这种道德困境，因为它们能带来戏剧性的张力。
When you have to choose between competing values, you might find yourself unsure if kindness matters more than courage or if loyalty should outweigh honesty. Playwrights and poets have grappled with these themes for centuries because our moral choices define us. They help us distinguish friend from foe. They inform whom we love and whom we hate. Today we examine the roots of our moral intuitions. We also tell the story of a man who asked
当你不得不在相互冲突的价值观之间做出选择时，你可能会发现自己不确定善良是否比勇气更重要，或者忠诚是否应该重于诚实。剧作家和诗人们几个世纪以来一直在探讨这些主题，因为我们的道德选择定义了我们。它们帮助我们区分敌友。它们决定了我们爱谁，恨谁。今天我们将探讨我们的道德直觉的根源。我们还要讲述一个人的故事，他问了
himself a question few of us do. Why do I believe what I believe? Understanding the origins of our moral beliefs and the implications of this quest on young minds, this week on Hidden Brain. Jonathan Haidt grew up identifying as a Democrat. It wasn't something he thought about a lot. His friends and family all identified with the left. So there was just the water I was swimming in. I didn't really think much about it. At the time in the 70s in high school,
自己一个我们很少有人会问的问题。为什么我相信我所相信的？理解我们道德信念的起源以及这一探索对年轻人的影响，本周的《隐藏的大脑》。乔纳森·海特在成长过程中一直认为自己是一名民主党人。这不是他经常思考的问题。他的朋友和家人都认同左翼。所以这就像是我游弋其中的水。我其实并没有多想。当时在70年代的高中里，
that's what was cool was to be on the left. I thought Republicans were stupid and evil, just like everyone around me seemed to think. And then once the Reagan era began in the 80s when I was in college, then it was just absolutely essential that you hate Reagan and everything he stood for. John and his classmates and professors at Yale University were outraged by Ronald Reagan's cuts in domestic programs, his efforts to roll back environmental regulations, and his support for South Africa's apartheid government.
支持左翼才是一件很酷的事。我以为共和党人又愚蠢又邪恶，就像我周围的所有人似乎都认为的那样。然后在80年代里根时代开始时，当我上大学的时候，绝对有必要痛恨里根以及他所代表的一切。约翰和他在耶鲁大学的同学和教授对罗纳德·里根削减国内项目、取消环境保护法规以及对南非种族隔离政府的支持感到愤怒。
I was very moralistic, very judgmental. I had strong opinions about what was right and wrong. So, you know, all they seem to care about is tax cuts. They don't care about poor people. It's just that I never actually met a conservative until really until I was in graduate school. And so it was just kind of obvious that if you care about people, humanity and the planet, you have to be a Democrat.
我非常有道德感，非常爱评判。我对什么是对、什么是错有着强烈的看法。所以，你知道，他们似乎只关心减税。他们根本不在乎穷人。只是我真的从来没有遇到过保守派，直到我读研究生的时候。所以这似乎是不言而喻的：如果你关心人、关心人类和地球，你就必须成为一名民主党人。
But after John finished a PhD in psychology and went to Chicago for a postdoctoral fellowship, three life-changing things happened to him. First, he started to work with Richard Schweder, a cultural anthropologist at the University of Chicago. The senior scholar taught John the first commandment of his field. Quick judgments are antithetical to curiosity. When you swiftly pigeonhole people into good guys and bad guys, you never learn anything. Learning to see, to observe with our preconceptions, was the essential tool of the social scientist.
但在约翰获得心理学博士学位并前往芝加哥进行博士后研究后，三件改变他一生事情发生在他身上。首先，他开始与芝加哥大学的文化人类学家理查德·施韦德合作。这位资深学者向约翰传授了他这一领域的第一诫。快速的判断与好奇心背道而驰。当你迅速把人划分为好人和坏人时，你永远学不到任何东西。学会带着我们的先入之见去观看、去观察，是社会科学家的基本工具。
Outside the classroom, John's leisure activities were teaching him the same thing. Okay, well, so here I have to turn us onto a track that I've never done before. So this was in June of 1993. I took LSD for the first time with my friends from graduate school. And here I was post-hoc at Chicago. I'd been interested in Buddhism and Hinduism for a long time. I'd read the Bhagavad Gita. And then I tried these drugs, first LSD, and then it was so transformative that I then
在教室外，约翰的闲暇活动也在教导他同样的事情。好吧，那么在这里，我要把我们带入一条我从未走过的新轨道。所以这是在1993年6月。我和研究生的朋友们第一次尝试了LSD（麦角酸二乙酰胺）。当时我在芝加哥做博士后。我长期以来一直对佛教和印度教感兴趣。我读过《薄伽梵歌》。然后我尝试了这些药物，先是LSD，然后它是如此具有变革性，以至于我后来
tried psilocybin mushrooms a few times. And the effect that these drugs had on me changed not just my perspective but my personality. So before June 11th, 1993, I was very judgmental, self-righteous, and when I went on this trip, it was like I was taken out of my world, out into a space where I could look down on the world, and see not just my world, but an infinite set of worlds, just out there, all doing what they're doing,
又尝试了几次迷幻蘑菇。这些药物对我的影响不仅改变了我的视角，还改变了我的性格。所以在1993年6月11日之前，我非常爱评判人、自以为是，而当我踏上这段迷幻之旅时，就像把我从我的世界里带了出来，带到了一个空间，在那里我可以俯视这个世界，看到的不仅是我的世界，还有无限个世界，它们就在那里，各自做着它们的事，
and it all was okay. There's a feeling that this is just the universe playing out the way it needs to. All the beauty, all the ugliness, it's all just part of the universe, the way it is. But I recently came across this beautiful passage from the poet Rumi. He says, out beyond ideas of wrongdoing and right doing, there is a field. I'll meet you there. When the soul lies down in that grass, the world is too full to talk about. Ideas, language, even the phrase each other, doesn't make any sense. And that's exactly what happened to me.
这一切都挺好的。有一种感觉，这只是宇宙在按照它需要的方式运行。所有的美，所有的丑，都只是宇宙的一部分，它本来的样子。但我最近偶然读到诗人鲁米的一段美丽的文字。他说，在超越对错的想法之外，有一片田野。我在那里等你。当灵魂躺在那片草地上时，世界丰富得无法用言语表达。观点、语言，甚至是“彼此”这个词，都失去了意义。而这正是我所经历的。
That same year, John went on another trip, a physical trip, to India. He spent a few months in the temple town of Bhubaneswar, about 250 miles from Calcutta, or Kolkata as it is known today. This is really the turning point of my life, is that year 1993. I was there to study ideas of purity and pollution. I had done graduate work in my PhD on the emotion of disgust as a moral emotion. And in India, throughout South Asia,
同年，约翰进行了另一次旅行，一次实地旅行，去了印度。他在加尔各答（现称加尔各答）以东约250英里的寺庙小镇布巴内斯瓦尔度过了几个月。这真的是我人生的转折点，就是1993年那一年。我去那里是为了研究纯洁与污染的概念。我读研究生、攻读博士学位时做过关于将厌恶情绪作为一种道德情感的研究。在印度，在整个南亚，
and really in most of the world, there are very elaborate notions of purity and impurity or shuddha and asshuddha in Oria, in Sanskrit languages. And you find these ideas in the Hebrew Bible, you find them in ethnographies, they're almost universal ideas. And so I was there to interview people about them and really try to understand why do people care so much
实际上在世界上大部分地区，都有非常复杂的纯洁与不洁的概念，在奥里亚语和梵语中被称为shuddha和asshuddha。你在希伯来圣经中能找到这些概念，在人类学专著中也能找到，它们几乎是普遍存在的概念。所以我去那里是为了就这些概念采访人们，并真正试图理解为什么人们如此关心
about when you take a bath or what you eat before you pray. So the key thing about moral disgust is that the human mind sees properties in objects that are not material. So if somebody offered you a sweater that had been worn by Adolf Hitler, but it had been completely washed, would you wear it? And most people say, no, it has an invisible Hitler essence. It's contaminated.
什么时候洗澡，或者在祈祷前吃什么。所以关于道德厌恶的关键在于，人类的心智在物体中看到了非物质的属性。如果有人送你一件阿道夫·希特勒穿过的毛衣，但它已经被彻底洗干净了，你会穿它吗？大多数人会说，不，它有一种隐形的希特勒本质。它被污染了。
And a lot of stuff follows this law of contamination, and it's a moral property. Now, that might just seem like a little quirk of morality. But then, as I was reading ethnographies about a variety of societies, well, it turns out the great majority of societies have these very strong beliefs about how biological properties get transmitted and they have spiritual ramifications. So for example, before you pray, and this is true in Hinduism, Islam, Judaism, you have to prepare yourself. It seems arbitrary.
很多东西都遵循这种污染法则，这是一个道德属性。现在，这可能看起来只是道德上的一个小癖好。但是，当我阅读关于各种社会的人类学专著时，结果发现绝大多数社会都有这些非常强烈的信念，关于生物学属性是如何传递的，它们具有精神层面的影响。例如，在祈祷之前，这在印度教、伊斯兰教、犹太教中都是如此，你必须做好准备。这看起来很随意。
You have to bathe in a certain way or you have to avoid certain foods. But what I came to see is that it's a way of orienting your life as if you have divinity within you. Most people, most cultures, seem to proceed on the idea that we all have a little bit of divinity or God or something within us, and that obligates us to act
你必须以某种方式洗澡，或者你必须避免某些食物。但我所看到的是，这是一种调整你生活的方式，就好像你体内拥有神性一样。大多数人、大多数文化似乎都基于这样一种理念：我们体内都有那么一点神性、上帝或类似的东西，这迫使我们采取
in certain ways and not in other ways. So India, more than almost any place else, has very, very clear laws and rules about purity, pollution, bathing food, illness. The physical and the spiritual are very tightly intertwined in Hinduism. Bhubaneshwar's old town features an enormous ornately carved stone temple that is more than a thousand years old. When he was not doing his research, John would wander over to the temple
某种特定方式行事，而不是其他方式。因此，印度比几乎其他任何地方都有非常非常明确的关于纯洁、污染、洗浴食物、疾病的法律和规则。在印度教中，物质与精神紧密交织在一起。布巴内斯瓦尔的老城有一个巨大的、雕刻华丽的石庙，有上千年的历史。不做研究时，约翰会溜达到寺庙去
and watch the worshipers. It really felt like just entering a different world, and I was open to it in a way that I wouldn't have been if I was back in the United States. There's a different rhythm. There's a sense that the land, that everything, has a kind of a, like almost like a topography of purity. Like there are certain things that are holy,
观看信徒们。这真的感觉就像进入了一个不同的世界，而且我是以一种如果我回到美国就不会有的开放心态去对待它的。这里有一种不同的节奏。有一种感觉，土地、一切事物，都有某种几乎像纯洁地形学的东西。就像有些东西是神圣的，
or sort of like up in a sense, and there are other areas that are polluted. And it really felt like, you know, like moving from a two-dimensional world into a three-dimensional world. And I just had to learn to be sensitive to properties that I couldn't see in my older life. So much of what John saw in Bobaneshwar clashed with Western progressive notions of right and wrong.
或者在某种意义上像是高高在上的，而其他区域则是受污染的。这真的感觉就像是从一个二维世界进入了一个三维世界。我只是不得不学会对我在以前的生活中看不见的属性保持敏感。约翰在布巴内斯瓦尔看到的大部分东西都与西方进步主义关于对与错的观念相冲突。
Notions of purity and pollution attached themselves to different groups, which led to the ostracisms of the Hindu caste system. There was hierarchy, inequality, and sharp gender divisions. You know, a lot of Americans, young Americans, when they go to India, you know, they're offended by the poverty, they're offended by the hierarchy, they're offended by the sexism. But I was there to sort of pretend to be an anthropologist and to try to understand things. So I would be invited over to many homes for dinner, and the father would greet me and entertain me and talk expansively with me while his wife would be in the background
纯洁与污染的观念依附于不同的群体，这导致了印度教种姓制度的排外。这里有等级制度、不平等和严厉的性别划分。你知道，很多美国人，年轻的美国人，当他们去印度时，他们被贫困冒犯了，被等级制度冒犯了，被性别歧视冒犯了。但我去那里是为了假装成人类学家，并试着去理解事物。所以我会被邀请去许多家庭吃晚饭，男主人会迎接我、招待我并和我海阔天空地聊天，而他的妻子则会在背景里
serving and would rarely say anything. Now as a young progressive American, that would normally have offended me, but I was trying to understand, and over time, I got to see that a world in which it's not all about individuals, it's actually much more about groups, communities, families, and it's the opposite of egalitarianism, but that doesn't mean it's bad. It was like I could see people living in a network
端茶送水，很少说话。现在，作为一个年轻的进步派美国人，这通常会冒犯我，但我当时正试图去理解，随着时间的推移，我开始看到这样一个世界：它不完全关乎个人，实际上更多地关乎群体、社群、家庭，它是平均主义的反面，但这并不意味着它是坏事。这就像我看到人们生活在一个网络中，
where they couldn't just act based on what they wanted to do. They had to check with lots of people. They had to make sure things were okay. And this fits with one of the main concepts in cultural psychology, which is do you have an independent sense of self or do you have an interdependent sense of self? And we Americans have what Hazel and Marcus calls
在那里他们不能只根据自己想做的事行事。他们必须与许多人核对。他们必须确保一切都好。这符合文化心理学中的一个主要概念，即你拥有独立的自我感，还是拥有相互依赖的自我感？我们美国人拥有黑兹尔·马库斯（Hazel Markus）所说的
a big thick padded self. You know, we're like a giant billiard ball, we roll around where we want. But what I saw was people who live in networks, they are enmeshed, they can't just move around as they please. I don't want to idealize this. They're often very frustrated, especially women with their mothers-in-law
那种厚厚垫起来的自我。你知道，我们就像一个巨大的台球，随心所欲地到处滚动。但我看到的是生活在网络中的人们，他们被交织在一起，不能随心所欲地四处移动。我不想把这理想化。他们常常感到非常沮丧，特别是女性和她们的婆婆
and all kinds of complicated family relationships. It's not that it's necessarily happy, but it is just a very different way of living, which people are deeply enmeshed and embedded. So, John, you've said that your experience in India led you to step out of the Matrix. Is that a reference to the movie, The Matrix? Oh, yes, it's exactly the movie, The Matrix, based on the novel,
以及各种复杂的家庭关系。这不一定意味着幸福，但这确实是一种非常不同的生活方式，人们在其中深深地交织和嵌入。所以，约翰，你说你在印度的经历让你走出了“黑客帝国”。这是对电影《黑客帝国》的引用吗？哦，是的，正是电影《黑客帝国》，它改编自小说，
No Romance by William Gibson. And the key line is that the Matrix is a consensual hallucination. Now, as a social scientist, that's pretty damn good. Like, yeah, that's what society is. And that's kind of the miracle of human civilization. How to do this? Together, we construct a moral matrix, we live inside of it, we judge people harshly within our matrix and those in other matrices, and we don't know that we're in a matrix. When John returned to the United States, he found himself consumed with a question that
威廉·吉布森的《神经漫游者》。核心台词是：“黑客帝国”是一个共识幻觉。现在，作为一个社会科学家，这真的是太棒了。就像，是的，这就是社会。这也是人类文明的奇迹。如何做到这一点？我们共同构建了一个道德矩阵，我们生活在其中，我们在我们的矩阵以及其他矩阵中严厉评判他人，而我们却不知道自己身处矩阵之中。当约翰回到美国时，他发现自己被一个问题所困扰，
Keanu Reeves' character asks himself in the movie. How do you escape the matrix? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. As a young man, psychologist Jonathan Haidt absorbed the progressive values of his family and schools without question. But when he was nearly 30, John lived for a time in a socially conservative temple town in India. Many of the things he saw there clashed with his notions of right and wrong. But his mentor Richard Schueter had taught him that any system of morality must have
基努·里维斯饰演的角色在电影中问自己的问题。你如何逃离矩阵？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。年轻时，心理学家乔纳森·海特毫不质疑地全盘接受了其家庭和学校的进步主义价值观。但当他将近30岁时，约翰曾在印度的一个社会保守的寺庙小镇生活过一段时间。他在那里看到的许多事情与他关于对与错的观念相冲突。但他的导师理查德·施韦德教导他，任何道德体系都必须
helped people coexist. If it failed to do that, it would have gone extinct. So even when he had objections to a moral system. It was worth asking why it came about and how it helped people who subscribed to it. One thing Schwaeter taught me is that every society is expert in some parts of human experience and somewhat ignorant in others. And so even though I certainly prefer
帮助人们共存。如果它做不到这一点，就会灭绝。因此，即使他对某个道德体系有异议，也值得去探究它是如何产生的，以及它是如何帮助那些认同它的人的。施韦德教给我的事情之一是，每个社会都是人类经验某些部分的专家，而在其他部分则有些无知。所以尽管我当然更喜欢
Western liberal democracies, the sense of anomy or meaninglessness that haunts us in the West is something that really was not much in evidence in a very saturated religious, thick morality kind of place. Now there are certain practices like dowry, which lead to all kinds of terrible distortions in marriage and treating young women terribly. So again, I am not here to defend the Indian social order in general, but it is one of the great ancient civilizations with an extraordinary wisdom
西方自由民主制，但在西方困扰我们的失范感或无意义感，在那个宗教氛围浓厚、道德浓郁的地方并不明显。现在确实有一些习俗，比如嫁妆，这导致了婚姻中各种可怕的扭曲，并对年轻女性造成了可怕的虐待。所以再次说明，我不是在这里为印度的社会秩序本身辩护，但它是伟大的古代文明之一，拥有非凡的智慧
tradition. We have to really credit India and this tradition with giving us Buddhism, with giving us these ideas about the veil of Maya, about life is in some way an illusion, and we're better off if we understand that than if we just act as though what we see is reality. When John returned to the United States, he realized that his certainties about his own secular progressive moral matrix had disappeared. His feelings of self-righteousness and superiority toward those with different moral frameworks had evaporated. He also noticed that many Americans also had views that overlapped with the moral frameworks he had observed in India. Religious and political conservatives in the United States also placed a high premium
传统。我们必须真正赞誉印度和这一传统为我们带来了佛教，带来了关于摩耶之网（veil of Maya）的思想，关于生命在某种程度上是一种幻觉，如果我们理解这一点，就会比仅仅表现得好像我们所看到的就是现实要好得多。当约翰回到美国时，他意识到自己对自身世俗进步主义道德矩阵的确信已经消失了。他对持有不同道德框架的人的自以为是和优越感也烟消云散了。他还注意到，许多美国人的观点也与他在印度观察到的道德框架有重叠之处。美国的宗教和政治保守派同样高度重视
on tradition, on order. They too were likely to see ordinary objects imbued with sacred meaning. Why do some people care more about being egalitarian, while others care more about loyalty and tradition? Why do some cultures glorify individual autonomy, while others prioritize the family or the community? I was already becoming an intuitionist. I was already coming to see that it's really got feelings and intuitions that drive morality. So I thought that actually the best metaphor is the tongue, the taste buds. All humans have the same five taste receptors, sweet,
传统和秩序。他们同样倾向于将普通物体视为被赋予了神圣的含义。为什么有些人更关心平等，而另一些人更关心忠诚和传统？为什么有些文化美化个人自主权，而另一些文化则将家庭或社群置于优先地位？我当时已经成为一个直觉主义者。我当时已经开始认识到，真正驱动道德的是内心感受和直觉。所以我认为最好的隐喻其实是舌头，是味蕾。所有人类都有相同的五个味觉受体：甜、
sour, salt, bitter, and umami, a kind of a meat flavor thing. Yet our cuisines are different. So there's something universal, the five taste receptors, but cultures build upon that. They build a cuisine that is different. You can't just build any cuisine, but we don't all like the same cuisine. I thought, wow, this is a great metaphor for morality. John started to look for the moral equivalent of taste receptors.
酸、咸、苦、鲜（一种肉类风味的味觉）。然而我们的烹饪方式各不相同。所以有些东西是普遍的，即五个味觉受体，但各文化在此基础上进行构建。它们构建出不同的烹饪体系。你不能凭空构建任何烹饪体系，但我们并非都喜欢相同的烹饪体系。我想，哇，这真是个绝佳的道德隐喻。约翰开始寻找道德上的味觉受体。
What were the underlying drivers, the foundations that lay beneath the bewildering array of moral frameworks that you see around the world? And the most obvious one is that we're mammals and as mammals we have babies and we care for these helpless babies. And so if we see any sign of a cute thing that's suffering, boy, does it get us. We feel like, oh my God, I've got to help this thing. So that hit me as a pretty strong moral intuition.
那些潜在的驱动力是什么？是哪些基础支撑着世界各地令人眼花缭乱的道德框架？最明显的一个是，我们是哺乳动物，作为哺乳动物，我们有婴儿，我们照顾这些无助的婴儿。所以如果我们看到任何可爱的事物在受苦的迹象，天哪，我们真的会被触动。我们会觉得，噢天哪，我必须帮帮这小家伙。所以这让我觉得这是一个相当强烈的道德直觉。
Reducing harm to others and protecting the vulnerable had to be one of the first pillars of any moral system. To be a good person is to care about others. You know, while I was making up this theory, you know, I was having kids and to see the way kids react to their stuffed animals and the way they get really upset if you sit on the stuffed animal. Like, wow, that's the care foundation right there.
减少对他人的伤害和保护弱者，必定是任何道德体系的首要支柱之一。做一个好人就是要关心他人。你知道，当我构建这个理论的时候，我有了孩子，看到孩子们对他们的毛绒玩具的反应，以及如果你坐在毛绒玩具上他们会感到多么沮丧。就像，哇，这正是关怀的基础。
They feel the pain of you sitting on their stuffed animal. Our sense of fairness is the second moral taste receptor. It's why kids are so quick to holler, that's not fair. If a sibling gets a bigger scoop of ice cream. There's a lot of research originally from Robert Trivers on reciprocal altruism, how we evolved to like to do favors for people, but we keep track of it because then they'll do us a favor in return and we don't want to get ripped off. So we've got all kinds of internal programming about fairness, exchange, cheating, catching
他们能感受到你坐在他们毛绒玩具上的痛苦。我们的公平感是第二个道德味觉受体。这就是为什么孩子们总是那么快地大喊“这不公平”。如果兄弟姐妹得到了更大一勺冰淇淋。有很多最初来自罗伯特·特里弗斯（Robert Trivers）关于互惠利他主义的研究，关于我们是如何进化到喜欢帮别人忙的，但我们会记着账，因为这样他们以后也会回报我们，而我们不想被坑。所以我们拥有关于公平、交换、欺骗、抓
cheaters, and it would be hard to argue that that's not part of our original equipment. In Western countries, both progressives and conservatives value the moral foundation of caring. They also value fairness, but their cuisines have different flavors when it comes to this aspect of morality. So fairness is so interesting because everyone, every society cares a lot about fairness,
获骗子的各种内部程序，很难说这不是我们原始装备的一部分。在西方国家，进步派和保守派都重视关怀这一道德基础。他们也重视公平，但在涉及道德的这一方面时，他们的烹饪方式有着不同的风味。所以公平是非常有趣的，因为每个人、每个社会都非常关心公平，
but it turns out there are two, there are a couple of different kinds of fairness. All around the world people are sensitive to if somebody or some group is taking more than they're giving. We then get very mad at them. That's unfair. They're exploiting us. Progressives care more about equality, especially equality of outcomes, and they think it's unfair if society ends up with big discrepancies of outcome. Whereas conservatives or free market libertarians would say, look, if somebody starts a business and creates more value, I want him to end up with a lot more than someone who doesn't. So everyone thinks they value fairness, and the other side doesn't. But there are some conflicting notions of fairness.
但事实证明，有两种，有几种不同种类的公平。世界各地的人们对某个人或某个群体是否“付出少于索取”都非常敏感。然后我们会对他们非常生气。这不公平。他们在剥削我们。进步派更关心平等，尤其是结果平等，他们认为如果社会最终出现巨大的结果差异，那就是不公平的。而保守派或自由市场自由主义者会说，听着，如果有人创办了一家企业并创造了更多价值，我希望他最终得到的比不这样做的人多得多。所以每个人都认为自己重视公平，而对方不重视。但确实存在一些相互冲突的公平观念。
The other three moral taste receptors that John identified were deeply informed by what he saw in India. Loyalty, sanctity and a respect for authority. John says Americans on the political right tend to value these qualities much more than progressives. So loyalty, it was really about are you a good member of your group? And humans evolved to be tribal creatures. We very quickly do us versus them. We love team sports for that reason. And loyalty is we're kind of monitoring each other. Are you really a team player or are you out for yourself?
约翰确定的另外三个道德味觉受体，深受他在印度所见所闻的启发。忠诚、圣洁和对权威的尊重。约翰说，美国政治右翼的人往往比进步派更珍视这些品质。所以忠诚，其实是关于你是不是一个好的群体成员？人类进化成了部落生物。我们很快就会进行我们与他们的区分。我们热爱团队运动也是出于这个原因。而忠诚就是我们互相监督。你真的是一个团队合作者，还是只为自己打算？
And here too we find stronger intuitions about loyalty tend to be found on the right than on the left. The next one is authority versus subversion. And that's, do you see the world as having structures that are necessary for society to function and it is incumbent upon all of us to respect those structures? Or do you say, no, you know, anything about authority is inequality is oppression, if there are statues,
在这里，我们同样发现，对忠诚更强烈的直觉更多地存在于右翼，而不是左翼。下一个是权威与颠覆。那是，你是否认为世界拥有社会运转所必需的结构，并且我们所有人都理应尊重这些结构？还是你会说，不，你知道的，任何关于权威的东西、不平等就是压迫，如果有雕像，
let's pull them off their pedestals. And this is again, part of our culture war. The right is livid at the way the left seems to attack the American founding fathers and statues. So it's a basic difference over whether authority, tradition, structure are valuable, or are they constraints on individuals? And then there's purity tradition, structure, or valuable, or are there constraints on individuals? And then there's purity or sanctity,
让我们把它们从底座上拉下来。这也是我们文化战争的一部分。右翼对左翼攻击美国开国元勋和雕像的方式感到愤怒。所以这是一个根本分歧，即权威、传统、结构是有价值的，还是对个人的束缚？然后是纯洁与传统、结构是有价值的，还是对个人的束缚？然后是纯洁或圣洁，
which is again this idea that things have invisible essences that we need to honor. So there used to be a debate in the 90s about flag burning. Should we amend the constitution to prevent anyone from burning the flag? And on the left, people said it's just a piece of cloth, and if people burn it as an act of expression, political expression, well, that's free speech. But people on the right are more likely to feel that there is an essence in the flag.
这也是那种认为事物具有我们需要尊重的无形本质的观点。所以在90年代曾有过关于焚烧国旗的辩论。我们是否应该修改宪法以阻止任何人焚烧国旗？在左翼，人们说这只是一块布，如果人们把它作为一种表达方式、政治表达来焚烧，嗯，那是言论自由。但右翼人士更有可能觉得国旗中存在着一种本质。
That's why you must never let it touch the ground. There's all kinds of rules about it. It's more than a material object. And that's the dividing line. As John reflected on his own upbringing and the views of nearly everyone he knew in high school and college, he saw that he and his family and friends had prioritized two moral foundations. Progressives were deeply animated by the moral foundation of caring, reducing harm especially to the vulnerable. And they cared about reducing discrepancies in outcomes because that signaled unfairness.
这就是为什么你绝不能让它触地。关于它有各种各样的规则。它不仅仅是一个物质物体。这就是分水岭。当约翰反思自己的成长经历以及他在高中和大学认识的几乎所有人的观点时，他发现他和他的家人、朋友优先考虑了两个道德基础。进步派深受关怀这一道德基础的激发，特别是减少对弱者的伤害。他们关心减少结果上的差异，因为那标志着不公平。
And progressive moralities are mostly based on those too. Whereas social conservatives, and this was certainly true in India, social conservatives also value a sort of loyalty, like group loyalty loyalty, authority and purity and sanctity. Those three additional taste receptors. So I started putting this metaphor out to try to argue with my fellow psychologists and philosophers that, you know what, we need to rethink morality because all of our research here is just on American morality and it's actually on American progressive morality. We're not even including our own conservatives.
而进步派的道德主要就基于这两点。然而社会保守派，这在印度当然是真的，社会保守派还珍视一种忠诚，比如群体忠诚、权威、纯洁和圣洁。那另外三个味觉受体。所以我开始提出这个隐喻，试图向我的心理学家和哲学家同行们论证，你知道吗，我们需要重新思考道德，因为我们这里的所有研究都只是关于美国道德，而且实际上是关于美国进步派道德。我们甚至没有把我们自己的保守派包括在内。
That's kind of what got me launched on this idea, which again comes in part from Richard Schwaeder, that the moral domain is actually very broad around the world. And the real story is, how did it come to be so narrow in secular progressive circles in Western countries. To drive his point home, John came up with an analogy. He asked his fellow progressives to imagine a restaurant. I developed this story about a restaurant owner who did some research and found out that sweetness is the most pleasant taste.
正是这一点让我开始思考这个想法，这再次部分来自于理查德·施韦德，即世界各地的道德领域其实非常广泛。而真正的问题是，它怎么会在西方国家的世俗进步派圈子里变得如此狭隘？为了阐明他的观点，约翰想出了一个类比。他请他的进步派同行们想象一家餐馆。我编写了这个关于餐馆老板的故事，他做了一些研究，发现甜味是最令人愉悦的味道。
So he opens a restaurant that serves only sweeteners. And you can come in and there's a menu, there's a whole menu, you can get different kinds of honey, different kinds of maple syrup, but it's all sweeteners. You know, and I tell the fanciful story of me walking in and being puzzled by what the hell's going on, why do you only serve sweeteners? And the guy says, well, you know, because that's what people want. Progressives and conservatives unconsciously prioritize different moral foundations. Each group lives inside its own matrix, but things its consensual hallucination must be universal. This routinely leads to conflict.
所以他开了一家只供应甜味剂的餐馆。你可以进来，这里有一份菜单，有一整份菜单，你可以买到不同种类的蜂蜜、不同种类的枫糖浆，但它们全都是甜味剂。你知道的，我讲述了一个异想天开的故事：我走进去，对到底发生了什么感到困惑，为什么你们只供应甜味剂？那家伙说，嗯，你知道的，因为那是人们想要的。进步派和保守派在无意中优先考虑了不同的道德基础。每个群体都生活在他们自己的矩阵之中，却认为他们的共识幻觉必然是普遍的。这通常会导致冲突。
I think one of the clearest places to look for left-right differences is in intuitions and morals around the family and family structure. And what we see is that in progressive families, there's much more of the idea that the parents are not authorities, they don't just lay down the law, they talk with their kids. I was just reading recently about a movie, I think it's called Gentle Parenting, where you never discipline the kids,
我认为寻找左右翼分歧最清晰的地方之一是在围绕家庭和家庭结构的直觉和道德中。我们看到的是，在进步派家庭中，更多地存在这样一种观念：父母不是权威，他们不仅是颁布法律，他们会与孩子交谈。我最近刚读到关于一部电影的文章，我想它叫温和育儿（Gentle Parenting），在那里你从不惩罚孩子，
you try to talk with them. And so on the far left, I think people are very uncomfortable with authority and they have a very strong sense that you have to treat everyone gently and with care. Whereas conservatives say, no, you have to have a respect for authority. You've got to learn right from wrong.
你试着与他们交谈。所以在极左翼，我认为人们对权威非常不舒服，并且有一种强烈的观念，即你必须温柔且充满关怀地对待每个人。而保守派则说，不，你必须对权威有敬畏之心。你必须学会明辨是非。
If you stray, there has to be some punishment. And in the long run, this is what's best for you and respect for authority. You've got to learn right from wrong. If you stray, there has to be some punishment. And in the long run, this is what's best for you and best for society. So if I love you, I'm gonna teach you right from wrong. I'm not just gonna try to reason with you gently. And so on all kinds of issues around the family, we see a big left-right difference. In fact, there was just an article in the New York Times
如果你误入歧途，必须有一些惩罚。从长远来看，这对你最好，并且要尊重权威。你必须学会明辨是非。如果你误入歧途，必须有一些惩罚。从长远来看，这对你最好，对社会最好。所以如果我爱你，我会教你明辨是非。我不会只试着温柔地跟你讲道理。因此，在围绕家庭的各种问题上，我们看到了巨大的左右翼分歧。事实上，《纽约时报》刚刚发表了一篇文章，
about how dog training is now polarized this way and progressives, when they train their dogs, they don't want to give them orders, they want to be their friends, whereas conservatives, they want an obedient dog. One of the benefits of what came to be known as Moral Foundation's theory was it gave people a peek into what life was like in another matrix. It gave people a chance to understand those with whom they disagreed. We were doing this work in the 90s as the culture war was heating up and it really began to be clear that moral foundations theory was actually very useful in understanding the culture war. And this
关于狗的训练现在是如何以这种方式极化的，进步派在训练他们的狗时，不想对它们下达命令，他们想成为它们的朋友，而保守派则想要一只听话的狗。被称为道德基础理论的东西带来的好处之一，是它让人们得以一窥另一个矩阵中的生活是怎样的。它让人们有机会理解那些与他们意见不合的人。我们在90年代文化战争升温时做这项工作，并且开始清楚地看到，道德基础理论在理解文化战争方面实际上非常有用。这
is actually one of the most gratifying parts of being a researcher, you put things out in the world, and then you get emails from people saying, oh, thank you for your work. I finally understand my father-in-law. And you realize, oh, wow, you know, yeah, what happened to you is like, what happened to me? Like you actually get outside your moral matrix and you can disagree with someone without hating them
其实是作为研究人员最令人满意的部分之一，你把东西放到世界上，然后你收到人们的电子邮件说，哦，谢谢你的研究。我终于理解我的岳父了。并且你意识到，哦，哇，你知道的，是的，发生在你身上的事就像发生在我身上一样。就像你真的跳出了你的道德矩阵，你可以不同意某人的观点却不恨他们，
because you see that they are a human being pursuing ends or values that you can at least understand even if you don't prioritize. And when that happens, now the world is a very, very different place. It's not full of good and evil people. It's full of different people and you can have ideas about how we can improve it.
因为你看到他们是一个追求着你至少能够理解的目标或价值观的人，即使你没有把它们放在优先地位。而当这种情况发生时，世界现在就变成了一个非常非常不同的地方。它不再充满好人和恶人。它充满着不同的人，你可以对我们如何改进它产生想法。
But if your idea is we got to defeat the evil ones, that's kind of the history of the world and it tends not to lead to a good place. Once he saw how people's views were informed by their moral taste receptors, John found himself becoming less ideological. He started to feel that healthy societies need a mix of progressive and conservative ideas.
但如果你的想法是我们必须打败邪恶的人，那差不多就是世界历史的轨迹，而它往往不会通向一个好的地方。一旦他看到人们的观点是如何被他们的道德味觉受体所塑造的，约翰发现自己变得没有那么意识形态化了。他开始觉得健康的社会需要进步主义和保守主义思想的融合。
Not because I think the answer is always in the middle, but because I see the need for a kind of a yin-yang formulation, that is, progressives are super sensitive to certain kinds of injustice and they drive forward rights revolutions, but if they're totally in charge and there's no break, you get chaos, you get collapse, left-wing revolutions tend to work out really, really badly. And if the right is in charge and there's no countervailing,
不是因为我认为答案总是在中间，而是因为我看到了对一种阴阳结合的需求，也就是说，进步派对某些类型的不公正超级敏感，他们推动权利革命，但如果他们完全掌权而没有刹车，你就会得到混乱、崩溃，左翼革命往往会产生非常非常糟糕的结果。而如果右翼掌权且没有制衡，
you tend to get all kinds of social patterns that are repressive, that are brittle, that are exclusionary. So I became a committed, principled centrist. Around this time, John met a man named Greg Lukinov. Greg is a lawyer who ran an organization focused on issues of free speech, especially on college campuses. The group mostly tried to restrain administrators from infringing on student freedoms. But starting in the early 2010s, Greg noticed something. Students on many campuses were demanding more intervention from administrators rather than less. When controversial speakers
你往往会得到各种压制性的、死板的、排他性的社会模式。所以我成了一个坚定的、有原则的中立派。大约在这个时候，约翰遇到了一个名叫格雷格·卢金诺夫（Greg Lukianoff）的人。格雷格是一名律师，他经营着一个专注于言论自由问题的组织，特别是在大学校园里。该组织主要试图限制行政人员侵犯学生的自由。但从2010年代初开始，格雷格注意到了一些事情。许多校园里的学生要求行政人员进行更多的干预，而不是更少。当有争议的发言者
came to campus, it was now the students rather than the administrators who tried to keep them at bay Now Greg is prone to depression and he had a suicidal depression in 2007 Fortunately, he called 911 at the last moment and they talked him into going into treatment when he was released from the hospital He took therapy in CBT cognitive behavioral therapy and he learned to identify Cognitive distortions. That's what CBT is all about. You see that your mind goes into these patterns, catastrophizing, black and white thinking, overgeneralizing.
来到校园时，现在是学生而不是行政人员试图将他们拒之门外。现在格雷格容易抑郁，他在2007年曾有过一次自杀性抑郁。幸运的是，他在最后一刻拨打了911，他们劝说他去接受治疗。当他从医院出院时，他接受了CBT（认知行为疗法）治疗，并学会了识别认知扭曲。这就是CBT的全部意义所在。你看到你的思维陷入了这些模式：灾难化、非黑即白思维、过度概括。
And so Greg had learned to recognize those patterns in himself and talk himself out of them. That's 2007. Fast forward to 2013, 2014. Greg sees students saying, if this speaker comes to campus, people will die, you know, or they would label people. He's a fascist. So these are cognitive distortions. And Greg's idea was that somehow these college students are learning to think in these distortions. Somehow college is teaching them to do that. And if they do that, they're going to get depressed.
所以格雷格学会了在自己身上识别这些模式并说服自己摆脱它们。那是2007年。快进到2013年、2014年。格雷格看到学生们说，如果这个发言者来到校园，人们会死，你知道的，或者他们会给人贴标签。他是个法西斯分子。所以这些都是认知扭曲。而格雷格的想法是，不知何故，这些大学生正在学习以这些扭曲的方式思考。不知何故，大学正在教导他们这样做。如果他们这样做，他们就会抑郁。
If cognitive behavioral therapy reduced depression by teaching people to fight their tendency to catastrophize or overreact, Greg's idea was that young people were being exposed to a kind of reverse cognitive behavioral therapy that was making them more depressed. I thought that was a really brilliant idea. And I had just begun to see examples of this on campus. We were reading stories from around the country about microaggressions and students demanding
如果认知行为疗法通过教导人们对抗他们将事情灾难化或过度反应的倾向来减少抑郁，格雷格的想法是，年轻人正在接触一种反向的认知行为疗法，这让他们更加抑郁。我认为这是一个非常 brilhant 的想法。我才刚开始在校园里看到这方面的例子。我们读到来自全国各地关于微侵犯的故事，以及学生们要求
trigger warnings and safe spaces. All this started in 2014. It was not there in 2012. So Greg comes to talk to me and I think his idea is brilliant. And I volunteer to help him write it up and so we did and we sent it to the Atlantic and it was published in August of 2015 and They gave it the title the coddling of the American mind Which we were a bit uncomfortable with because we didn't want to be accusing the students of being coddled But actually it kind of worked because coddle just means overprotected and we've done that
触发警告和安全空间。这一切都始于2014年。2012年时还没有。所以格雷格来找我谈话，我认为他的想法太棒了。我自愿帮他把它写下来，于是我们照做了，并把它寄给了《大西洋月刊》，它于2015年8月发表了。他们给它起了个标题《娇纵美国心灵》，我们对此有点不舒服，因为我们不想指责学生们被娇纵了。但其实它效果挺好，因为“娇纵”只是指过度保护，而我们确实这样做了。
We have vastly overprotected our kids in the real world and made them feel that the world is dangerous. I teach a course at NYU Stern called Work, Wisdom, and Happiness. I was co-teaching it with Barry Schwartz, a professor at Swarthmore who wrote a book on wisdom. And he assigned an article from The New Yorker that involved death and dying. And, you know, I can imagine that some students would find it uncomfortable. But we long had the idea in the Academy that discomfort is not a reason to not talk about something.
我们在现实世界中对我们的孩子进行了极度的过度保护，让他们觉得世界是危险的。我在纽约大学斯特恩商学院教授一门名为“工作、智慧与幸福”的课程。我和斯沃斯莫尔学院教授巴里·施瓦茨（Barry Schwartz，他写过一本关于智慧的书）共同教授这门课。他布置了一篇来自《纽约客》的涉及死亡和临终的文章。而且，我能想象一些学生会觉得它不舒服。但我们在学术界长期以来一直有一种观点：感到不舒服并不是不谈论某事的理由。
In fact, you know, our founding story is really Socrates, the gadfly of Athens, trying to make people uncomfortable. But suddenly we started getting reactions from students, whether it be in my teaching evaluations or other comments, that I shouldn't assign something that makes people uncomfortable. Or if you do, you should have given a trigger warning. We'd never seen that before. This was new. So in some ways, I'm seeing a connection between the work that you were doing with the moral foundations theory, where you basically argue that one of the things that people on the left care about deeply is protecting people from harm, and the examples you're telling
事实上，你知道的，我们的奠基故事其实是苏格拉底，雅典的牛虻，试图让人感到不舒服。但突然之间，我们开始得到学生的反应，无论是在我的教学评估中还是其他评论中，认为我不应该布置让人感到不舒服的东西。或者如果你这样做了，你应该给出触发警告。我们以前从未见过这种情况。这是新鲜事。所以在某些方面，我看到了你一直在做的道德基础理论工作之间的联系，你在其中基本上认为，左翼人士深深关心的其中一件事就是保护人们免受伤害，以及你向我讲述的发生在大学校园里的那些例子，人们说，事实上，所有这些我们以前没有想过的新的伤害维度，我们应该做点什么。
me of what happened on college campuses, of people saying, in fact, there are all these new dimensions of harm that we hadn't thought about previously, that we should do something about. Absolutely. Absolutely. I came to believe during this work that monomania is dangerous. Monomania means focusing on one thing, becoming obsessed with one thing. And you might say, well, care, how could that be bad? Care is lovely. But what happens if you have a one foundation morality and everything's about care? Well, you treat everyone as vulnerable, as easily harmed, you wanna protect them, and before you know it, you have violated children's needs for challenge.
绝对是。绝对是。我在做这项工作期间开始相信，单狂热（monomania）是危险的。单狂热意味着专注于一件事，对一件事着迷。你可能会说，好吧，关怀，这怎么可能是坏事？关怀是可爱的。但如果你拥有一个单一基础的道德，一切都关乎关怀，会发生什么呢？好吧，你把每个人都视为脆弱的、容易受到伤害的，你想保护他们，在你不知不觉中，你就违背了孩子们对挑战的需求。
We are not fragile, children are not fragile. We actually need to be challenged in order to grow. And what an extraordinary disservice we're doing to our students if we let them graduate from college, thinking that ideas that upset them should be shut down. As young people and their parents increasingly experience the real world as a place of danger and threat, John realized there was a powerful new force that offered them comfort and safety. Instead of venturing outside the home, kids were retreating into virtual worlds and video games. Instead of asking someone out on a date, teenagers
我们并不脆弱，孩子们也不脆弱。事实上，我们需要接受挑战才能成长。如果我们让学生大学毕业时，还认为让他们感到不安的想法都应该被封杀，那么我们对学生所做的事情将是多么巨大的伤害啊。随着年轻人及其父母越来越觉得真实世界是一个充满危险和威胁的地方，乔纳森意识到有一股强大的新力量正在为他们提供慰藉和安全感。孩子们没有去户外冒险，而是退缩到了虚拟世界和电子游戏中。青少年们没有约别人出去约会，
were hiding behind their phones. And in place of close, deep friendships, intimacies that come with the risk of heartbreak and betrayal, social media platforms offer a seductive world of likes, emojis, and positivity. Mr. Zuckerberg, you and the companies before us, I know you don't mean it to be so, but you have blood on your hands. You have a product. You have a product that's killing people. That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta.
而是躲在手机后面。社交媒体平台没有提供伴随着心碎和背叛风险的亲密、深厚的友谊，而是提供了一个充满点赞、表情符号和积极情绪的诱人世界。扎克伯格先生，你和我们面前的这些公司，我知道你们不是有意这么做的，但你们手上沾满了鲜血。你们的产品。你们的产品正在杀害人类。欢迎回来。你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan. Psychologist Jonathan Hyde works at New York University. He is the author of The Righteous Mind, Why Good People Are Divided by Politics and Religion, and The Anxious Generation, How The Great Rewiring of childhood is causing an epidemic of mental illness. John, your most recent research focuses on the mental health of young people and the alarming spike in anxiety and depression. How does this connect to your earlier work, both your research on moral foundations and your theories about cognitive distortions among college students? Is there a through line here? Well, yes, there is. So we knew that rising depression and anxiety
这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。心理学家乔纳森·海特在纽约大学工作。他是《正义之心：为什么好人总是分帮结派》以及《焦虑的一代：童年重组如何引发心理疾病大流行》一书的作者。乔恩，你最近的研究重点是年轻人的心理健康，以及焦虑和抑郁症的惊人激增。这与你早期的工作有何联系，包括你关于道德基础的研究以及你关于大学生认知扭曲的理论？这里面有一条贯穿始终的主线吗？嗯，是的，确实有。所以我们知道，不断上升的抑郁和焦虑
was part of what was going on, because if you're chronically anxious, you see everything is more threatening. You see a visiting speaker as more dangerous. And some researchers said like, oh no, you guys are all wrong. There's no epidemic, the kids are all right. And I thought, oh, no, you guys are all wrong. There's no epidemic. The kids are all right.
是其中的一部分原因，因为如果你长期焦虑，你会觉得一切都更具威胁。你会觉得来访的演讲者更危险。一些研究人员说，哦，不，你们全错了。没有流行病，孩子们都很好。我想，哦，不，你们全错了。没有流行病。孩子们都很好。
And I thought, oh, did I make a mistake here? So I created a Google document, made it public, and I put in all the research I could find on mental health. And it began to tell the story of an epidemic of anxiety and depression that began around 2012, 2013. anxiety and depression that began around 2012-2013. John believes that our worries about harm in the real world and the rise of social media giants like Twitter, Facebook, Instagram and TikTok have driven countless young people to seek refuge in their phones, add great harm to their mental health.
我想，天哪，我是不是弄错了？于是我创建一个谷歌文档，将其公开，并把我能找到的所有关于心理健康的研究都放了进去。它开始讲述一场始于2012、2013年左右的焦虑和抑郁大流行。始于2012-2013年左右的焦虑和抑郁。乔恩认为，我们对现实世界中伤害的担忧，以及推特、脸书、Instagram和TikTok等社交媒体巨头的崛起，促使无数年轻人到手机中寻求庇护，这极大地损害了他们的心理健康。
Let's look at the data from these long-running, longitudinal studies that the federal government runs. One is the monitoring the future study, which surveys high school students every other year, and variable after variable about anxiety, depression, optimism, pessimism, life has no meaning, whatever you want to graph, it's a hockey stick. That is, things look okay up to 2010 and then all hell breaks loose around 2012-2013. So you're seeing more anxiety, more depression.
让我们来看看联邦政府运营的这些长期纵向研究的数据。一个是“监测未来”研究，该研究每两年对高中生进行一次调查，关于焦虑、抑郁、乐观、悲观、生活毫无意义等一个又一个变量，无论你想绘制什么图表，它都是一个曲棍球棒的形状。也就是说，2010年之前情况看起来还算正常，然后2012到2013年前后，所有麻烦都爆发了。所以你会看到更多的焦虑、更多的抑郁。
That's right. You're not seeing like more schizophrenia or bipolar. It's all related to mood disorders, anything about anxiety and depression and interestingly and tragically, it's not just like kids are saying that they're more anxious. Hospital admissions for self-harm show exactly the same pattern, a really terrifying hockey stick for girls. And especially, my God, you look at preteen girls, girls 10 to 14, they didn't used to cut themselves, but the rate for the preteen girls has more than tripled. And we see the same thing with suicide.
没错。你并没有看到更多的精神分裂症或双相情感障碍。这全都与情绪障碍有关，任何关于焦虑和抑郁的事情，而且有趣且悲惨的是，这不仅仅是孩子们说他们更感到焦虑。因自残而入院的人数显示出完全相同的模式，对女孩来说，这是一个真正可怕的曲棍球棒曲线。尤其是，天哪，你看看青春期前的女孩，10到14岁的女孩，她们过去不会割腕自残，但青春期前女孩的自残率已经增加了一倍以上。我们在自杀方面也看到了同样的情况。
Suicide rates have gone up for girls to the highest levels they've ever been at. It started in the early 2010s, sometimes around 2008. And for young girls, the rates are up more than triple. rates are up more than triple. It's worth stating here that while many scholars agree with John that social media is a big part of the problem, US Surgeon General Vivek Muthi issued an advisory in 2023 linking social media usage to the youth mental health crisis. There are scholars who feel other explanations
女孩的自杀率已经上升到有史以来的最高水平。它始于2010年代初，大约在2008年左右。对于年轻女孩来说，这个比率上升了三倍多。比率上升了三倍多。这里值得一提的是，虽然许多学者同意乔恩的观点，即社交媒体是问题的重要组成部分，但美国卫生局局长维韦克·穆蒂在2023年发布了一项建议，将社交媒体的使用与青年心理健康危机联系起来。也有学者认为其他解释
are also possible. People have all kinds of theories. Like why did it start in 2012? So a lot of people say, oh, you know, school shootings. That was the Newtown massacre. And after that, kids had these terrifying lockdown drills. Well, okay, that does fit the timing. It's true.
也是可能的。人们有各种各样的理论。比如为什么它会在2012年开始？所以很多人说，哦，你知道，校园枪击案。那是纽敦惨案。在那之后，孩子们进行了这些可怕的封锁演习。好吧，好吧，这确实符合时间。这是真的。
But why do girls in New Zealand, Australia, Canada, and the UK, why do they all start cutting themselves in 2013? It doesn't make any sense. Other people would say, oh, global has to be global. Oh, the global financial crisis. You know, I mean, lots of families had all kinds of financial difficulties starting in 2008, but that makes no sense either because things were really bad in 2008, 2009, 2010, but there's no change on the mental illness grabs.
但是为什么新西兰、澳大利亚、加拿大和英国的女孩，为什么她们都在2013年开始割腕自残呢？这毫无意义。其他人会说，哦，全球范围的必须是全球性的。哦，全球金融危机。你知道，我的意思是，许多家庭从2008年开始遇到各种各样的财务困难，但这也没有意义，因为2008年、2009年、2010年情况真的很糟糕，但在精神疾病图表上没有任何变化。
And then the economy starts getting better and better and better. And from 2011 through 2019, gets better and better and better. Stock market goes up, unemployment goes down, depression and anxiety and self-harming suicide keep going up and up and up. So give me a sense of how much time young people are spending on their phones. You've collected some of this evidence. How much time are young people spending on their phones on these social media platforms and other apps?
然后经济开始变得越来越好。从2011年到2019年，情况变得越来越好。股市上涨，失业率下降，但抑郁、焦虑和自残自杀却一直在不断上升。那么，请让我了解一下年轻人花在手机上的时间有多少。你收集了一些这方面的证据。年轻人花在手机、这些社交媒体平台和其他应用程序上的时间有多少？
So what we find is that teenagers are spending around 8 to 10 hours a day on their phones, and then there are other devices as well. Preteens are spending something like 6 to 8 hours a day on their phones, and then there are other devices as well, preteens are spending something like six to eight hours a day on their phones. So these are astonishing numbers. And what that means is that it pushes out almost everything else.
我们发现，青少年每天花在大约8到10个小时在手机上，此外还有其他设备。青春期前的儿童每天花大约6到8个小时在手机上，还有其他设备，青春期前的儿童每天花在大约六到八个小时在手机上。所以这些数字是惊人的。这意味着它挤占了几乎所有其他事情。
It pushes out sleep, exercise, time with friends, time paying attention to teachers. So that's one way to estimate it. The other is there's a question that Pew asks, which is, how often are you on the internet? And one of the options is I'm almost constantly on the internet. And we've seen this with young people, you know,
它挤占了睡眠、锻炼、与朋友相处的时间、注意老师讲课的时间。所以这是一种估算方法。另一种方法是皮尤研究中心提出的一个问题，即你上网的频率如何？其中一个选项是我几乎一直在上网。我们在年轻人身上看到了这一点，你知道的，
whatever they're doing, the phone is there, they're talking to someone, but they're looking up stuff, they're talking to someone, but they're actually also texting. And so about 45, 40% say they're on almost constantly. That means something like 16 hours a day. Now, it's not 16 hours a day looking at the screen, but if you're doing what's called continuous partial attention,
无论他们在做什么，手机都在那里，他们在和某人说话，但他们在查东西，他们在和某人说话，但他们实际上也在发短信。因此，大约45%、40%的人表示他们几乎一直在线。这意味着每天大约16个小时。现在，这并不是说一天中有16个小时在盯着屏幕，但如果你在做所谓的持续分散注意力的事情，
you're always thinking about what's going on in that chat, what's going on on this fight on Instagram, you're never fully present in the physical world, you're never fully present with the people around you. And so what that means is that young people, at least half of them, say that they're basically never fully present. They're always partially online. That's terrifying. You've talked about why girls might be affected more than boys. Can you talk about this a little bit more, John, because the numbers really are quite striking. Teenage girls seem
你总是想着那个聊天里发生了什么，Instagram上的这场争吵是怎么回事，你从来没有完全活在现实世界中，你从来没有完全和周围的人在一起。这意味着年轻人，至少有一半的人表示他们基本上从来没有完全在场。他们总是部分在线。这太可怕了。你曾谈到为什么女孩受到的影响可能比男孩更大。你能多谈谈这个吗，乔恩，因为这些数字确实非常引人注目。十几岁的女孩似乎
to be really affected far worse than teenage boys. That's right. So the simple component is just that they use it a lot more, but you have to say why do they use it more? And here, I think the master psychological variable is this difference between two sort of high level motivations. So everyone has a motivation for agency and for communion. Agency is the desire to be active in the world,
受到的影响远比十几岁的男孩严重得多。没错。所以简单的组成部分就是她们使用得更多，但你必须说明为什么她们使用得更多？在这里，我认为关键的心理学变量是这两种高水平动机之间的差异。每个人都有追求能动性和建立联系的动机。能动性是渴望在世界上积极行动，
to make things happen, to be a force. And communion is the desire to connect, to be part of a group, to be included. So all kids have both. But on average, boys are more, they seek out more, they seem to have stronger agency needs and a little less communion, girls the opposite.
让事情发生，成为一股力量。而连结是渴望连接、成为群体的一部分、被包容。所以所有的孩子都有这两种动机。但平均而言，男孩更多，他们寻求更多，他们似乎有更强烈的能动性需求，而连结需求稍少，女孩则相反。
So what these companies do, they know their audience, they're all desperate to get, you know, if Instagram doesn't grab 11 and 12 year olds, they're going to lose them to TikTok. They look at girls' concerns, fears and motivations. They're afraid of being left out. If someone's talking about them, they need to know. So they've crafted Instagram to maximally hook young women. And it seems to offer communion. It seems to offer community. But once you get in, you're now constantly
所以这些公司在做什么，他们了解他们的受众，他们都迫切希望获得，你知道的，如果Instagram不能吸引11和12岁的孩子，他们就会把他们输给TikTok。他们关注女孩的担忧、恐惧和动机。她们害怕被排挤。如果有人在谈论她们，她们需要知道。所以他们精心设计了Instagram，以最大程度地吸引年轻女性。它似乎提供了连结。它似乎提供了社区。但一旦你进入其中，你现在就会不断
preyed upon about your insecurities, about your looks, about your life, about what people are saying about you. So for all these reasons, social media appeals to girls more, it traps them more, and it harms them more. For many kids, they get bullied, and bullying on social media is unlike anything before because it's not just like a few kids making fun of you or a corner you were threatening you during school. What many kids are finding now is social media makes it possible for them to be bullied 24-7 even on weekends, anonymously. And it's like everyone is talking about them or laughing about them. So for some kids, it's the bullying which leads to suicide. For some kids, it's the chronic social comparison. For some kids it's the fact that they get caught up by sexual predators. There is such a range of harms that come to
成为你的不安全感、你的外表、你的生活、人们对你的议论的猎物。由于所有这些原因，社交媒体对女孩更有吸引力，它们更多地困住了女孩，并对她们造成了更大的伤害。对许多孩子来说，他们遭受了欺凌，而社交媒体上的欺凌不同于以往的任何欺凌，因为它不仅仅是几个孩子取笑你，或者你在学校里被某个角落的人威胁。许多孩子现在发现的是，社交媒体使他们有可能遭受7×24小时的欺凌，即使在周末也是匿名的。这就像每个人都在谈论他们或嘲笑他们。因此，对一些孩子来说，是欺凌导致了自杀。对一些孩子来说，是长期的社会比较。对一些孩子来说，是他们被性掠夺者盯上了的事实。对
these kids, especially girls. So it's not just the opportunity cost, it's positively harming many of them. I think if you talk to most teenagers today or young people today, they will tell you that in fact social media is a way for them to connect with other people, to have friends with other people. If you took away their phones and took away their social media, you Jonathan Haidt would in some ways be depriving them of their social lives. Well, that's true, but you got to look at this one.
这些孩子，尤其是女孩，会受到各种各样的伤害。所以这不仅仅是机会成本的问题，它正在对其中的许多人造成实质性的伤害。我想如果你跟今天的大多数青少年或今天的年轻人交谈，他们会告诉你，事实上，社交媒体是他们与其他人联系、与其他人交朋友的一种方式。如果你拿走他们的手机，拿走他们的社交媒体，你乔纳森·海特在某种程度上就是在剥夺他们的社交生活。嗯，这确实是真的，但你得看看这个。
Suppose you took everyone, you took all children, and you locked them up in individual cells in a gigantic prison, and then you connect them via tin cans with strings, so they can talk to each other on their tin cans with strings. And then you say, I'm gonna take all your tin cans with strings, well, yeah, that would be bad. But what if you said to them,
假设你把所有人，你把所有的孩子，把他们关在一个巨大监狱的单独牢房里，然后你用带绳子的罐头把他们连起来，这样他们就可以用带绳子的罐头互相交谈。然后你说，我要拿走你们所有带绳子的罐头，好吧，是的，那会很糟糕。但是如果你对他们说，
how about we break you out of prison and you just like meet up and talk? Most kids would like that. And so for example, there was recently a study published with college students asking them, how much would we have to pay you to not use TikTok or Instagram for a month? And they give some number, I think on average,
我们带你们越狱，你们只要见面聊天怎么样？大多数孩子都会喜欢这样。所以，例如，最近发表了一项针对大学生的研究，询问他们：我们要付给你多少钱，你才肯一个月不用TikTok或Instagram？他们给出了一个数字，我想平均下来，
it was like $50. Because they don't wanna be kicked off when everyone else is on. But then the experimenter said, okay, we're actually gonna try to get most people in your university to quit Instagram and TikTok for a month. If we succeed in doing that,
大约是50美元。因为当其他所有人都在用时，他们不想被踢出去。但随后实验人员说，好吧，我们实际上要试着让你们大学里的大多数人在一个月内戒掉Instagram和TikTok。如果我们成功做到了这一点，
how much would we have to pay you to go off? So the college students said, you know what? If I could pay to make that happen, I would. So they're trapped. And this is the key thing that everyone needs to understand about social media. It is a social trap. The kids are stuck on it, but they're only there because everyone else is. What is the solution to this problem here, John?
我们要付给你多少钱，你才肯戒掉？所以大学生们说，你知道吗？如果我能付钱让这件事发生，我愿意。所以他们被困住了。这就是每个人都需要了解的关于社交媒体的关键事情。它是一个社交陷阱。孩子们被困在上面，但他们呆在那里只是因为其他所有人都在上面。这个问题的解决方案是什么，乔恩？
And of course, now we're venturing into the realm of policy, not necessarily psychology. But these are devices that are used by millions of people. These are companies that are here to stay. These are networks that are very hard to dismantle. What is your solution? Delay. Delay. There's lots of talk about how to make it less toxic. But given what we know about child development, about what kids need, how much kids need physical play to be in touch with other kids, to have independence, for God's sakes,
当然，我们现在涉足的是政策领域，不一定仅仅是心理学。但这些是数百万人使用的设备。这些是会长期存在的公司。这些是非常难以解散的网络。你的解决方案是什么？延迟。延迟。有很多关于如何使其毒性降低的讨论。但鉴于我们对儿童发育的了解，对孩子需求的了解，孩子们多么需要进行体育玩耍、与其他孩子接触、拥有独立性，看在上帝的份上，
let's let them get through childhood and at least early puberty before we throw them into this pit of craziness and despair. So what if we had a norm, not a law, a norm, saying, no smartphones before high school. Let them get through middle school with just flip phones. Flip phones are great.
在我们把他们扔进这个充满疯狂和绝望的深渊之前，让我们让他们度过童年，至少度过青春期早期吧。如果我们制定一个规范，不是法律，而是一个规范，规定高中之前没有智能手机，会怎么样？让他们只用功能手机度过初中。功能手机很棒。
They can call and text you, they can call and text their friends. Don't give a smartphone till high school. That would do an enormous amount of good. At least get them through early puberty where their brain is rewiring very rapidly before they're spending all day long on social media and other platforms.
他们可以给你和他们的朋友打电话发短信。直到高中才给智能手机。那将带来巨大的好处。至少让他们度过青春期早期，那时他们的大脑正在以极快的速度重新布线，然后再让他们花一整天的时间在社交媒体和其他平台上。
That's norm number one. Norm number two, no social media till 16. The only reason most people let their kids have an Instagram account in sixth or seventh grade is because everyone else has one. So if your kid's the only one who's not on Instagram, then you're condemning them to social isolation. But if half or most of the kids aren't on, then it's very easy to say no.
这是第一条规范。第二条规范，16岁之前没有社交媒体。大多数人让孩子在六年级或七年级拥有Instagram账号的唯一原因是因为其他所有人都有一个。所以如果你的孩子是唯一一个不上Instagram的人，那么你就是在判处他们社会隔离。但如果一半或大部分孩子都不上网，那么说“不”就非常容易了。
The third norm is phone-free schools. I mean, it's kind of like, you know, imagine running a heroin treatment clinic and you say, you know, okay, you're all heroin addicts. You can bring your heroin in, but you have to keep it in your pocket. Please don't shoot up while you're in the clinic. They can't do that, they're addicts. And in the same way, most schools say, oh yeah, yeah, we ban phones, yeah. We tell the kids, you can't take it out during class time. But of course they do, they text during class,
第三个规范是无手机学校。我的意思是，这有点像，想象一下运营一个海洛因戒毒所，然后你说，好吧，你们都是海洛因瘾君子。你可以把你们的海洛因带进来，但必须放在口袋里。在诊所里千万别注射。他们做不到，他们是瘾君子。同样，大多数学校说，哦，对，对，我们禁止手机，对。我们告诉孩子们，上课时间不能拿出来。但他们当然会拿出来，他们在课间发短信，
they text between classes, they text and are on social media at lunch. So the phones are devastating to learning, to inclusion, to friendship, and the teachers all hate them. Why are we letting kids bring their phones into class? They should be locked up in a phone locker as soon as they walk in, and then they get them back at the end of the day.
他们在课间发短信，他们在午饭时发短信和玩社交媒体。所以手机对学习、对包容、对友谊是毁灭性的，老师们都很讨厌手机。为什么我们要让孩子把手机带进课堂？他们一走进来，手机就应该锁在手机储物柜里，然后等到一天结束时再拿回来。
And the fourth norm is far more free play and childhood independence. We can't just take away the phones and say, okay kid, sit and look at the wall. We have to restore the play-based childhood in which kids meet up after school and do stuff together. So if you did those four things, I think we would bring down rates of mental illness
第四个规范是更多的自由玩耍和童年独立。我们不能只是拿走手机然后说，好吧，孩子，坐着看墙。我们必须恢复以玩耍为基础的童年，让孩子们放学后聚在一起做一些事情。所以如果你做了这四件事，我认为我们将降低心理疾病的发病率，
very substantially within one or two years. So there's a paradox here because on the one hand, John, you're saying that we're coddling kids, we're overprotecting them, you've written a book called The Coddling of the American Mind, but you're saying that on social media and in digital spaces, we're not doing enough protection. It feels like those are opposite ideas. They're not at all opposite.
在一到两年内大幅降低。所以这里有一个悖论，因为一方面，乔恩，你说我们在娇惯孩子，我们在过度保护他们，你写过一本书叫《美国心灵的娇惯》，但你说在社交媒体和数字空间中，我们做得保护还不够。感觉这些是截然相反的想法。它们一点也不相反。
I see the apparent contradiction. Once you realize smart phones are like the cuckoo bird. So the cuckoo bird lays her egg in other bird's nests. That egg hatches quickly and then the baby hatchling pushes out all the other eggs. A smart phone does that. When you give your kid a smart phone, it's gonna push out almost everything else.
我看到了表面上的矛盾。一旦你意识到智能手机就像杜鹃鸟。所以杜鹃鸟把蛋产在其他鸟的巢里。那只蛋孵化得很快，然后小雏鸟把其他所有的蛋都挤了出去。智能手机就是这样。当你给你的孩子一部智能手机时，它会挤占几乎所有其他事情。
They're gonna sit there their whole childhood on the phone. My basic argument in the anxious generation is that we have overprotected our kids in the real world where they desperately need a huge amount of experience. And we've underprotected them online, which is this insane adult space that is not made for children in which a lot of kids are getting torn up.
他们整个童年都会坐在那里玩手机。我在《焦虑的一代》中的基本论点是，我们在现实世界中过度保护了我们的孩子，而他们在现实世界中迫切需要大量的经验。而我们在网络上对他们保护不足，网络是一个疯狂的成人空间，并不是为儿童制造的，许多孩子在那里被撕裂。
So there's no contradiction. John increasingly finds himself going back in his mind to Bhubaneshwar. Yes, there was inequality, hierarchy, and sexism in India. But the interdependence of people living in a dense social network served as a moat against despair. He says a similar moat is providing some protection against mental health issues for many conservative kids in the United States. While we've known for a long time that liberals are a little bit more depressed, a little bit less happy than conservatives,
所以根本没有矛盾。乔恩越来越发现自己的思绪回到了布巴内斯瓦尔。是的，印度存在不平等、等级制度和性别歧视。但生活在一个密集的社交网络中的人们相互依存，这成了抵御绝望的护城河。他说，类似的护城河也为美国许多保守派孩子提供了一些保护，使他们免受心理健康问题的困扰。虽然我们长期以来一直知道，自由派比保守派稍微抑郁一点、稍微没那么快乐，
that gap exploded after 2012. In other words, when you trace out these graphs, you know, 2000, 2005, 2010, everything goes up around 2012, 2013, but conservative kids only go up a little, liberal kids go up more, boys go up, little girls go up more, liberal girls go up the most. So this really hit liberal girls.
但这种差距在2012年之后爆发了。换句话说，当你描绘这些图表时，你知道的，2000年、2005年、2010年，所有的数据都在2012、2013年前后上升，但保守派孩子的上升幅度很小，自由派孩子的上升幅度更大，男孩上升了，女孩上升得更多，自由派女孩上升得最多。所以这真的打击了自由派女孩。
So people who say that religion is important to them or who are raised in religious families, they're only a little bit worse off. Whereas people who were secular who say religion isn't important, they're much worse off. And so the way I interpret it is, conservatives and religious people are more rooted and anchored in their local communities.
所以那些说宗教对他们很重要或者在宗教家庭中长大的，他们的状况只稍微差一点。而那些世俗的、说宗教不重要的人，他们的状况要糟糕得多。所以我对它的解读是，保守派和宗教人士在他们的本土社区中根基更深、锚定更深。
They're more parochial, whereas progressives are more secular, less religious, more cosmopolitan, less rooted, more citizens of the world. And that used to actually be conducive to happiness. But then when everything switches on to digital, when everything switches on to phones around 2012, 2013, the kids who were rooted and anchored are not much affected
他们更加地方化，而进步派更加世俗化、宗教色彩更淡、更具有世界主义色彩、根基更浅、更像是世界公民。这过去实际上是有利于快乐的。但随后，当一切都在2012、2013年前后转向数字网络、转向手机时，那些有根基、有锚定的孩子受到的影响并不大，
because they still have roots with people. Whereas the kids who were not rooted got swept away in a tidal wave of anony or normlessness. So Gene Twenge has shown that liberal girls spend by far the most time on social media, more so than any other group, and the kind of stuff they're consuming makes them feel the world is dangerous and stacked against them. So for all these reasons, it turns out, gender, politics, and religion explain a lot of the
因为他们与人之间仍然有根基。而那些没有根基的孩子则在匿名或无规范的浪潮中被卷走了。所以让·特温格（Jean Twenge）已经表明，自由派女孩花在社交媒体上的时间最多，远远超过任何其他群体，她们消费的这类内容让她们觉得世界是危险的，并且对她们不利。由于所有这些原因，事实证明，性别、政治和宗教解释了2012年以来谁的状况更差的很大一部分
variants in who is worse off since 2012. Jonathan Haidt is a psychologist at New York University. He is the author of The Righteous Mind, why good people are divided by politics and religion, and The Anxious Generation, how the great rewiring of childhood is causing an epidemic of mental illness. John, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Shankar, what a pleasure. You can find more of our conversation with Jonathan
差异。乔纳森·海特是纽约大学的心理学家。他是《正义之心：为什么好人总是分帮结派》以及《焦虑的一代：童年重组如何引发心理疾病大流行》一书的作者。乔恩，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。尚卡尔，这是我的荣幸。你可以在我们的播客订阅《隐藏的大脑Plus》中找到更多我们与乔纳森·
Haidt on our podcast subscription, Hidden Brain Plus. In that episode, we'll explore how John's ideas about technology and mental health apply to adults. Also, ideas about how to flourish in our daily lives. She's had feelings of love and openness and communion with strangers, walking in a park that she'd been in many times. And here's what was so amazing. She was so moved by this experience that she wanted more. You can listen to that episode, which is called Six Practices to Elevate Your Life, and try Hidden Brain Plus for free by finding the show on Apple Podcasts. Just click on the episode and follow the prompts to sign up for your seven-day trial to Hidden
海特的对话。在那期节目中，我们将探讨乔恩关于技术和心理健康的观点如何适用于成年人。还有关于如何在日常生活中蓬勃发展的想法。她曾在一个她去过很多次的公园里散步时，感受到对陌生人的爱、开放和连结。令人惊奇的是。她被这种经历深深打动，以至于她想要更多。你可以收听那期名为《提升生活的六种实践》的节目，并在Apple Podcasts上找到这个节目，免费试用《隐藏的大脑Plus》。只需点击该节目并按照提示注册即可开始你的七天《隐藏的大脑
Brain Plus. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you'd like to hear more of our reporting on the intersection of technology and psychology, check out the show notes for this episode. You'll find links there for several hidden brain episodes that I think you'll enjoy.
Plus》试用。本节目由“隐藏的大脑传媒”制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、赖安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。如果你想听到更多关于技术与心理学交叉领域的报道，请查看本期节目的节目简介。你会在那里找到几个我猜你会喜欢的《隐藏的大脑》节目的链接。
I'm Shankar Vedantan. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们很快再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。